so we're going back to our little burger
stand where we had our demand curve in
terms of burgers per hour and now i want
to think about something from the
perspective of our our burger stand and
think about at any given point on this
demand curve how much revenue would we
get per hour and when i talk about
revenue for simplicity let's just think
of that's really just how much total
sales will i get in a given hour so let
me just write over here total revenue
total
revenue
well the total revenue is going to be
how much i get per burger times the
number of burgers i get so the amount
that i get per burger is price
so it's going to be equal to price and
then the total number of burgers in that
hour is going to be the quantity
is going to be
is going to be the quantity pretty
straightforward if i sell if i sell 10
things at five dollars i am going to
i am going to get 50 dollars of revenue
fifty dollars of sales in that hour now
let's think about what the total revenue
will look like at different points along
this curve right over here and actually
let's just let me just make a little
table right over here so if i'll make
one column
price
one column quantity
and then let's make one column total
revenue
total
total revenue
all right so let's look at a couple of
scenarios here well we could actually
look at some of these points that we
already have defined at point a over
here price is nine so i'll do it in
point a's color price is nine quantity
is two nine dollars times two burgers
nine dollars per burger times two
burgers per hour your total revenue is
going to be 18. and you can see it
visually right over here this height
this height right over here is nine and
this width right over here is two
and your total revenue is going to be
the area is going to be the area of this
rectangle because the height is the
price and the width is the quantity
so that total revenue is the area right
over there
now let's go to point well let me do a
couple of them just to just to really
make it clear for us let's try point b
so at point b when our price is eight
and our quantity is four four burgers
per hour our total revenue is going to
be eight times four which is 32 dollars
per hour and once again you can see that
visually the height here is eight and
the the width here so this height of
this rectangle is eight
and
the width is four the total revenue is
going to be the area
it's going to be the height times the
width just like that
now let's go
let's go to a point that i haven't
actually graphed here actually well let
me just actually i'll go through all the
points just for fun
so now at point c we have 550
550 is the price the quantity is nine
nine times five fifty nine times five is
forty five dollars and then you have
another 450 so that is 49
49 50. so once again it's going to be
the area it's going to be the area of
this rectangle area of that rectangle
right over there so you might already be
noticing something interesting as we
lower the price at least in this part of
our demand curve as we lower the price
we are actually increasing not just the
quantity we're increasing the total
revenue let's see if this keeps
happening
so if we go to point d if we go to point
d i'll do that same color
we have 450
450 and we are selling 11 units so 11
times 450 let's see that's going to be
44 plus 550 once again that is
49.50 so that this rectangle is going to
have the same area
as that pink one that we just did for
scenario c and i'll actually do just do
one more down here just to see what
happens because this is interesting now
we lowered the price and it looks like
things didn't change much and now let's
go let's just do one more point actually
for the sake of time
point e and i encourage you to try other
ones try f on your own point e
my price is two dollars per burger my
quantity is 16 burgers per hour i sell
a total of 32 burgers actually actually
let's just do the last one f just to
feel a sense of completion so one dollar
per burger i sell 18 burgers per hour my
total revenue when you multiply them is
per hour and once again that's the area
of this rectangle this short and fat
rectangle right over here and e
was the area
the total revenue at e was the area of
that
right over there and you could graph
these just to get a sense of how total
revenue actually changes with respect to
price or quantity let's let's plot total
revenue with respect to quantity so
let's try it out
so if you
if you'd let me plot it out so this is
going to be total revenue and this axis
right over here is going to be quantity
and we're going to once again go from
let's see this is 0 this is 5 this is
10.
this is 15 and this is 20 right over
here
and then total revenue let's see it gets
as high it gets pretty close to 50. so
let's go this is
20 30 40 and 50. so that's 50 40
20 and 10.
so when our quantity is 2 and our price
is 9 but we don't have price on this
axis right over here but when our
quantity is 2 our total revenue is 18.
so it's going to be something like
something like there
then when our quantity is 4 total
revenue is 32 when our quantity is 4
total revenue is
32 right about there
then when our quantity is 9 our total
revenue is almost 50 when our quantity
is 9 our total revenue is almost 50. so
right over there
and then when it's 11 it's also at that
same point 11 it's also
at that same point right over there and
then when our quantity is 16 our total
revenue is 32 16
so 32 right there and then finally when
our quantity is 18 our total revenue is
18 quantity is 18 our total revenue is
18. and what you see is that it's
plotting out a curve that looks like
this and if you remember some of your
algebra 2 this is
this is a concave downwards parabola
right over here and you can see there is
actually some point in which you can
maximize your total revenue and if you
really tried all the points here you
would see that that maximum point is if
you tried if you tried this point right
over here right at price five and
quantity ten at price five and quantity
ten in that hour you would sell fifty
dollars so this is the maximum point
right over there fifty
fifty dollars now the whole reason why
i'm talking about this i could have
talked about this independently of any
discussion of elasticity just to see how
total revenue relates to price and
quantity at different points in the
demand curve
but there is an interesting relationship
in that very first video and we actually
use this exact demand curve for it when
we explored elasticity we saw that up
here at this part of the curve let me do
this in a different color at this point
of the curve in orange
at this part of the curve in orange for
any change when you do a change in your
in your price since the prices are
pretty high
that is a much lower percent change in
price than the impact that you get on
quantity because over here although they
look like they're close the the
or i should say the absolute for every
one down we move in price we're moving
two up in quantity but that one down in
price is a very small percentage of
price because our prices are high here
and it's a very large percentage of
quantity right over here so you get huge
changes in percent quantity for very
small changes in price in this part of
the curve so this part of the curve is
elastic
elastic elastic
or you could say that its price
elasticity for demand is greater than
one you get larger changes in percent
quantity for a given change in percent
price now these parts of the curve down
here
these parts of the curve down here
we saw
the opposites happening you move one
down one unit down in price you move two
units to the right in quantity but over
here price is much lower so this is a
much larger chain percentage change in
price and this is a much smaller
percentage change in quantity so you get
large percentage changes in price for
small percentage change in quantity that
means that here you are relatively
inelastic
inelastic and then right over here right
at this point right in this region right
over here we saw that we had unit
we were unit elastic right over there so
there's an interesting relationship
going on
while we were so while we were elastic
this part right over here when we
lowered price when we lowered price in
this region while we were elastic when
we lowered price we got increases in
revenue so let me write this down and
this is generally two there's a couple
of boundary cases on the map that make
it a little bit you can't make it
absolutely true but while we are elastic
while we are elastic at the elastic
points of our demand curve a decrease in
price
price goes down
total revenue was going up
total revenue was going up you do a
price cut on this part of the demand
curve you get more revenue
then when you are at unit elasticity
then when you are at unit
unit elasticity
unit
elasticity
what was happening at unity elasticity
you were right at this point right over
here right at this point over here and
roughly and roughly when you do a price
cut and i'm going to say this was
roughly true your total revenue total
revenue stays constant
constant but just right at that point
right when you're going through that
unit elasticity point and then finally
when you are inelastic
inelastic
when large percent changes in price
result in not so large percent changes
in quantity demanded then a price
change going down
then a price change going down
a price change going down resulted in
lower total revenue resulted in total
revenue going down
and this should hopefully make a little
bit of intuitive sense because over here
over here at this point if given percent
change in price you were getting a
larger percent change in quantity so the
percent in price went down your percent
in quantity grew even more so you made
up any decrease in height with a
increase in width so your area increased
down here your decrease in percent price
wasn't made up for a decrease in percent
quantity so when you when you made your
when you made your rectangles a little
bit shorter you didn't you weren't able
to compensate by growing the width as
much and so you actually had a lower
area lower total revenue